the interesting thing about trying to
unravel the laws of nature is that yes
we have found some laws we understand
gravity to some extent we understand the
quantum world with some extent but we
don't understand everything we know that
there are some laws missing laws that we
haven't found yet
now what theoretical physicists do is
the following
they try to learn what we know so far
and they try to see where the limits of
today's knowledge lie and they try to go
beyond they try to make one step beyond
what is now and that is what is called
theoretical physics theoretical physics
is trying to see a law beyond the laws
we have there are at least two places in
our universe
where we know that we do not know what
laws apply those two places are inside
black holes and at the Big Bang in both
cases the the conditions surrounding
everything are so extreme that the laws
we know they break down and that is why
both these that is one reason why both
these places are so interesting to look
at for a long time gravity has told us
that nothing can escape the
gravitational grip of a black hole but
then in 1976 or 75 professor Stephen
Hawking discovered that it was not the
case that actually things could escape
black holes how did that come about
picture yourself in outer space there is
a black hole right in front of you you
don't see anything no light can come out
of it so it's like a dark patch that
distorts the the stars that are around
but there is this dark patch right in
front of you and you're far away and you
look at it and it's scary and you don't
want to get closer which is normal but
and respectable but what you know is
that gravity is not everything the
matter that surrounds you the light that
surrounds you obeys a different kind of
law they obey quanta
physics they obey the law of the quantum
world and everything we had known about
black holes until the mid-1970s was only
related to gravity
now what Hawking did at the mid-1970s is
to add some quantum aspects to all this
he took a quantum particle and threw it
in his mind towards the black hole to
see what would what would happen to it
and it found out that some part of that
particle was getting out of the black
hole that the black hole was evaporating
it was not the exact same particle he
has sent inside and that was that that's
what's tricky about this problem and
that's what's interesting about this
problem in the way that means that the
information gets bleached by a black
hole
why is that you you could imagine that
it's the same with an encyclopedia that
you would throw in the fire and you take
an encyclopedia you throw it in the fire
it's gone well not quite if you could
get back the ashes if you could collect
all the lights that was shown during the
the fire if you could get the heat and
everything you could build back the
encyclopedia it's not gone it's just
difficult to retrieve for black hole
it's worse if you throw an encyclopedia
inside what the black hole will
evaporate has nothing to do with the
Encyclopedia whatsoever you could have
thrown in something else so why is that
a problem
it is a problem because it means that
our universe has memory losses it means
that whatever a black hole has swallowed
would get inside never get back out and
we would never be able to understand the
past of our universe there are some
things that are not not retrievable at
all not just in practice but also in
theory and as it evaporates the black
hole eventually disappears completely
maybe and if it's gone where did the
information go about the the
encyclopedia where did it go we don't
know
and that's a problem because that's
called non unitarity that's the
static technical term for it and it
means that you do not you cannot use
physics to understand the history of
what happened before in a sense the
information paradox says that physics is
not going to give you the history of our
universe and you can fairly easily
understand that scientists did not like
that idea and people are still working
today on the way out of that problem
there are some solutions that have been
put forward none that I believe is
sufficiently convincing mathematically
to be considered the proof but people
have been working on that information
loss paradox problem since 1975 1976 and
in a sense maybe that the answer to that
question will come from this theory of
everything that everybody is looking for
you